Hello, I am David James. I lead our global sales engineering team here in the Webex see-pass solutions team
Webex connect is a product that I'll be taking you through
In this video series as a slightly deeper dive into the platform getting a little bit more technical
But hopefully not too technical
And yeah, let's get into it
Before I jump in you would have heard Brian ready talk about in video one the disconnect
And I cover the platform product story, so I'm not going to try and repeat his words too much
But maybe a little recap about why we built the platform that we built
So digital natives Ubers, Tetzlers, Netflix of the world other disruptors
They made it look very easy to
Manage this increasing complexity of all these emerging channels because they don't have all this legacy core business systems on the left hand side
So challenges around complex communication integration scale managing protocols
Single points of orchestration
They're not challenges that they face they didn't come with that tech debt
So the fragmentation of channels and consumer journey is an ultimately delivering poor personal experience
Is a lesser faced challenge for those guys
The problem for a lot of large enterprises
We pull millions of dollars into apps that promise great digital presence
But yet digital leaders digital natives still gain ground on us. They still grand gap gain ground on these companies, right?
They're building great platforms as well. They're building their own IP
And so how do we also start to look at it from a
big tech debt large legacy kind of financial services or healthcare or
enterprise type companies, how do we look at it from your perspective and
See how we can help you overcome this challenge
You know, we totally appreciate the modern enterprise for a lot of many systems applications to power their day-to-day
Operations and so this is not about moving away from those systems
This is not about one-stop shop potentially wasting years of cumulative investment
Whenever there isn't one-stop shop, we think the market is covered by an ever-growing list of best-in-breed vendors
Many different parts of our own business will probably want to bring their own technology
You've got e-commerce platforms payment solutions CRMs or the management systems fraud management systems
CRM and case management different transactional platforms
It's impossible to just buy a single data source or data lake and just process this all in one place the promise of a
Just one CDP even still isn't going to get you everything in one single place
So there's a compelling need to connect these about back-end systems essentially with these communication channels and create consistent customer experiences
So that's the bit that we focus on and we do this
Which we're going to talk about today and we've been talking through the series with WebEx connect this brings it together
It's a cloud communications platform. It doesn't rip or replace access glue connective tissue
It augments it plays well alongside these existing investments
So let's dive a little bit deeper into what this platform actually is and does and what's inside this box
So they help navigate through some of the different elements
We've broken the platform down into six key areas and they're the areas I'm going to talk to one by one
The central four pillars they essentially allow you to build and deliver great experiences right for your developers or your line of business working together or
individually
You've got your integrations into your own and systems. We're going to talk more about that
You've got your business logic and flow builder drag-and-drop if this then that logic
You've got AI conversational capabilities of course AI conversational automation is key in this day and age
especially with all the advancements in LLM and of course we wouldn't be a
Communication platform if we weren't going to talk to you about the communication channels and our rich
heritage and the future of messaging that we see there
Around this we have an enterprise grave wrapper. So think about control center service assurance layers reporting
Infrastructure management those types of things. So we'll also talk about that as well
So I'm going to bring them all to life a little bit more detail as we go through
Starting off with communication channel management. We think it's the key pillar really
We of course can expose these my rapi's and we can just be a simple API and
Partner for for you guys to just send payloads to us and we push to the messaging channel
We have 16 of these channels out box
We can even develop custom channels into your own
own channel of choice to bring your own channel we can almost call it and so a
Quick overview here would be that we are not just a tier one SMS aggregator in many markets as we're known in many markets
Which gives us the best price points the best deliverability and lowest latency and there's only a few of those tier one SMS aggregators in the world
But we also have a wider range of traditional channels like email voice our own app in that push SDK
Live chat SDK and I think more importantly as well as in terms of future proofing
We we have deep relationships with the likes of meta apple and Google
But what that actually means is we've launched first in market solutions on some of these
We have a future proof platform
So all of your communication channels under one proof the advantage for you working on a single platform
Your future proof you consolidate
And we insulate all the complexity of multi-channel of what's next of all of the different
Channel rich channel aware capabilities that you that you see across these emerging channels
And I'm talking about carousels and list pickers and rich buttons and all of the ways in which these channels become
Interactive and we give you those tools and capabilities in a very easy and intuitive manner within our platform
And I'll show you a little bit about that now
So first up from an API perspective simple send receive message when you log into the platform
You're going to see some of these services each services a name workspace that addresses a customer interaction use case for some context here
And we're not going to go deep into an overview of the platform
We have API documentation available on our developer portal
Helps developers navigate all of this has helpful code snippets and samples that aid that configuration
And so that when we do come back into the services you can use
apis for outbound communication
You can configure these outbound webhooks we call them very easily for incoming events
So an appointment reminder or something like that that might be coming in
And we have a set of authentication tokens for enterprise grade security as well. That's really important businesses need those
So typically an enterprise developers are responsible for the API integration
But messaging and content is often handled by functional teams in the line of business
So we have rich template management capabilities. We have things like
WhatsApp template management apis
That can all be managed from within the platform
SMS templates and other things here and I'm going to show you some of our email template capability as well
So we have an email our email composer just one of the channels and one of the
richer channel elements that we can show you here
While I'm showing this is because it allows you to do a couple of things
So you can import your own HTML and edit it from within the platform
This gives you rich previews on different devices, which is really cool
So you can see how that comes to life
But what a number of our customers really like doing our clients really like doing
Is using these configurable set of building blocks
We call them conditional logic and we things like partials
So blocks of code that can be consistent across multiple templates that you only edit once in one place
And this reduces the number of templates needed
An organization needs to manage essentially by using if this then that logic and really drives
Personalization based off your data. So highly targeted highly rich
And data driven campaigning messaging
Which is at the core of what I guess one of our value promises is
Okay, moving on to AI. We talked a little bit about this already
Let's go a step deeper. So what do we mean when we talk about conversation automation? So
This layer provides multiple options for conversation automation ranging from what we would call basic structured
scripted kind of menu driven bots to query based in FAQ bots
And even all the way through to fully unstructured, of course, the advancements in llm are slightly better for this but unstructured
natural language smart bots
And we we even have powerful integrations into bring your own bots
So if you wanted to bring a dialogue flow bot, we are not suggesting that you can only use our own IP when building these experiences
We we play nicely as I mentioned before and we can integrate into any bot platform
And you can propagate that into your your messaging
But if you want to use our own bot builder
We have a rich set of low code functions in here as well
Utilize invest in breed libraries in the market our own toolkit
and essentially we have some
Routine nlp functions that are very specific to messaging as well like date time recognition spell check
OCR things like that
A quick demo of our bot capabilities. So as mentioned key aspects of conversational experiences are chatbots
And this is our bot builder as part of WebEx connect
Here we can define our bot as you see here. We click into our bots. We see things like
status the languages supported
handover instructions
We can configure things like live agent fallback because of course if a bot fails what then happens as a very common use case
And we define as well in here things like articles and variants of those and then start to define responses to that input
So without getting too deep here. I think one thing that's really cool is we can define these on a channel by channel basis
What do we mean by that? So apple message for business, for example, might have rich list pickers
What's out has a click buttons and rich cards that you can pull through that are different
Whereas sms is just plain text only and what this means is
Because we have the channel where capabilities it prevents sms and plain text from being the lowest common denominator
Across these channel experiences allows us to focus on delivering the best experience across any channel
Again, one of our key themes, you know deliver the best experience across any channel broad, but also deep
Uh, we want to democratize the experience of building these to allow non-technical folks to participate as well
Again a step further
We also do things within our bot environment, of course around testing and previewing the bots
I said, I'm not going to go too deep
In this session today, but this allows us to create optimize the bot based on actionable data
Like sessions in the history of all the interactions. Of course, we are introducing
LLM driven bot development
What does that mean? It essentially means reducing training time for developers
Or to make the learning and efficiency of your chat bot. So again an ever-evolving toolkit here
With a constantly innovative roadmap
integrations and set up
Set up and management. So just going to talk a little bit about what does this mean?
So we think this is a usp for us in the cpass space as well
Many many companies have what you call a marketplace
So they might have some his ones we've done earlier
But we'll talk a little bit about how we can also integrate into basically any system of record on your side
So a quick context set that existing systems are designed
Usually for specific purposes like processing a payment
They're not designed for custom experience and many of these were designed a while ago as well
Before the kind of digital age that we're currently in and they were designed designed to augment
So you don't have to rip and replace. That's why we integrate into any system
We have a set of upcoming integrations that we do build out of the box that you can use
So you can see those on your screen here
Adding things like epic and server to those as we know that they are very common platforms with an organization
And we can make your lives a lot easier by building a custom node and I'll show you what I mean by that in a second
But unlike vendors who just provide out of the box integrations or marketplaces
We've rather flexibility and integrate with
Any existing business system and applications that are part of a vendor's tech stack as well as third party providers partner systems
And I think this is essentially where you can tailor the products to you the enterprise by building a custom palette of integrations
essentially build it once single configuration
multi-use and reuse them across multiple departments and workflows and control any downstream or changes to those and you only have to edit it once and it will
Especially propagate or and take effect across all customer journeys, which is really cool. Really powerful
So diving into custom integrations a layer deeper
So here you see our our integration palette
You can see how we go to create a custom node. You can see all the other integrations that are within this section
We're going to have a little bit of a deeper look here. You'll see us navigate through some quite technical components
Um, we'll see us look at things in the in the platform UI itself and how these are configured
Here's one we did earlier a dialogue flow one
We did earlier along with all the other customer integrations
We have configured in the tenant as we dive into it. You're going to see here
So we've built a post method custom node for intent detection
You can see the other methods available
The level of authorization we can configure and how we can pass parameters through in a dynamic or a static fashion
Sample response code we have we've got that from the other tab the google the google dialogue flow api docs
You can see the parameters that we've configured against those session id and the developers map those responses to node edges or outcomes
Success error timeout, etc. And then we can test and save this
And whilst this is perhaps a more technical configuration
As I said the brilliance of this these custom nodes is it's won't stay unconfigured as you see here
They can easily be used by anyone on the flow builder and you see us here simply dragging
Our dialogue flow node onto the palette from our list of integrations
Quickly configuring some basic details to add intent detection to an existing flow
And this will then essentially in this case evaluate an inbound message input from the customer and simply add
The past input variable into the node just like that
You've seen how easy it is to configure one and reuse it across any
so like
Okay, so you have a little introduction into our
Flow builder there on the previous on the previous example
I'm going to bring this to life a little bit more. What is our flow builder? Why does it matter?
so traditionally c pass caters to the last mile of
Essentially procuring numbers and apis for sending and receiving messages
apis and SDKs
So we showed you some of our api documentation up front and whilst that's great
And and it does abstract a lot of complexity in itself
It's very developer first and developer only you know
It still leaves a heavy lifting of writing application logic for automating customer journeys and interacting with business systems as we saw on the previous slide
Two developers, you know, you're not really getting economies of scale. You're redoing everything over and over
You can't quickly respond to changing business customer requirements
You can't quickly configure business logic through pre pre-built modules and nodes
You want to launch run in a serverless environment and you want interactive reports to analyze and optimize customer journeys
and so
We provide what we would say is more of a configure not code approach here helping it expand its talent pool a collaboration between
technical and non-technical users
Easiest pressure on it and speeds up go to market
And you can imagine a white boarding session a story boarding easily being reimagined with this physio like builder and mapping it onto
Onto this canvas step by step
And and our platform really does give IT the control over the tools integrations and automation capabilities
while inviting
analysts cx professionals and other live business users to collaborate across building great customer journeys
One way it doesn't alienate the developer one way it helps the developer and makes the developer more efficient
Is by these drag-and-drop building blocks and if we take a quick step in one one level deeper into what are these
So we basically created a set of
Nodes or functions
They could be known as the package up a bit of code and they perform a task that you don't have the code and build yourself
Tailor towards building great communications, right?
So think of them as like lego blocks or a set of building blocks
And we have everything from social hour nodes
So you can just open up a social hours node and say I don't want to send an sms between 9 am and 9 p.m
And then you can configure that
Out of ours response to do something different
We have packaged up otp multifactor authentication capabilities
We have packaged up the ability to take variables and to take and store and share variables between flows
And and include the interaction details store and track them and keep context and information across flows and across the customer journey
We also have
A custom business logic so you can write your own code bring your own code
We have an evaluate node where you can write json
Um, and and we of course have external connections as well
So you don't always want to build these integration rich integration nodes
You might just want to make an htp request to an external api service. You can do all of that from within these drag and drop nodes
And I talked about bring your own code and and us trying to make the developers more efficient
Definitely not alienate them
So one of the advancements and developments that we have on our roadmap at the minute that we are we are launching is
The ability to apply a large language model driven developer acceleration
Essentially we're integrating it into that driver script node where you can bring your own code
Provide prompts and queries that use generative ai to produce
The code snippet the developer needs
On their behalf to be using the customer journey just by typing in that prompt
Yeah, making life easy for them and of course if you are not a developer
This is an even more powerful feature for you essentially turning a platform from low code to almost no code at some point in the future
Okay, so i'm going to bring this to life now in a in a demo
There's a lot of capability here the channel you're going to see is apple messages for business
We're going to show a combination channels. Actually sms will be brought in as well
You'll see some conversational
Capabilities in here. You'll see some nlp
You'll see some of the otp thing. I just mentioned some payment features and some integrations
So, uh, hopefully this starts to make sense if it hasn't already at this juncture
So this flow kicks off
Customer messages in over apple messages for business and we automate the response
You can see us moving through the flow in the background and the customer handset shows what's happening on the customer experience side
We want to identify who this customer is. We don't know who they are
So they provide a mobile number which we do have in our crm and this allows us to do a one-time pin
Lookup so we can send them with authentication
Six digits seven digit code they put that in we immediately can look them up in sales for crm and say
Jordan, it's you
We verified you. We know who you are. We even know what you're talking about because we're an apple message for business
We can show them a rich image. We can show them a nest doorbell. We can show them what they've actually purchased
We can use some nlp in response when someone replies. Yes and open text
But we can also use some of apple's richer capabilities with the list picker as you see here to select that option
As we continue to triage through
We're able to then confirm an appointment. So we're integrating now
I'll be using a little bit of nlp date time day after tomorrow
We know day after tomorrow is you know, the 24th of august or in this case, it's the 4th of april
And so we can then structure that into a format that the back end system the appointment scheduling system
Understands and retrieve the available slots for jordan
Once we tell the system yet
Jordan has confirmed this appointment. Please put that on hold. We received the information back to say
Yep, that has been confirmed all good
We can confirm that with jordan and we can even offer the ability to pay by integrating with a rich apple capability of apple pay
a quick double tap and a look at the face and jordan has not only completed his
Appointment scheduling, but he's also paid for it too. And of course the brand has saved a significant amount of money on
Very lightweight customer service experience
So we've talked about the middle four pillars
I said there was
I guess this wrapper
Let's call it around the outside that makes this truly truly enterprise grade and to be truly enterprise grade
Um, you need all of this you need to be able to enforce it and security policies actual insights
You need these controls
role-based access controls for different users and different teams to only give access to certain people who need certain access
Read write capabilities
You need to be able to deliver communications with the latest brand and legal guidelines and opt-in and opt-out policy and consent
Etc that we all manage
um
We have rich dashboards to evaluate journey data
Optimization manage renew and enforce these customer preference and contact frequency policies as well
And this can all be done from a single platform
And it really all should be done from a single platform because it's the only way to really guarantee
You are effectively managing this across the entire enterprise without one customer told us
But they don't know where 20 of their messages originated from so even just looking into an issue with a short code or or a bot
Or a whatsapp id or um any or an email id or or voice number
Um, you don't have to scrap around looking in multiple different systems
You can manage it all under one umbrella and I actually have access to everything very very quickly to resolve customer issues
Or make changes to services within the organization
And the other uh part to that was the service assurance and infrastructure management and essentially
None of this would mean anything without um being able to monitor the heartbeat are your systems responding
Solving problems before they happen
Knowing that things are working um and ensuring you have the uptime the zero downtime up to updates
the availability disaster recovery all required um
Um handling peaks, you know highest customer volume
We deploy some of the largest messaging programs in the world
Um, and so this world class support account management professional services that come with it
Uh, we are a very trusted partner to help you deliver your communication programs
Here's a quick look at some of those enterprise grade features
So we wanted to show you some of the enterprise rich features
We can configure tenant iraqi here. You'll see in the drop down as we put it up
Groups teams roles and access permissions can all be configured for this
We can allow multiple teams
This means to benefit from our platform in a managed and controlled
Environment
I'll explain what that means in a second
Each of these teams has the access to procure their own numbers assets relevant to that team in that region
in self-service manner
Certainly to go to it every time they want to do something or buy something however
Um all the while we have the ability for an overall admin or it team to have full visibility control over all the programs
And they can manage all of the reports for the specific services either across the entire enterprise
Or as I said, each team can manage their own reports
So we've talked a little bit about
the platform and just to finish off
Some of you guys must be wondering a little bit about webx and the rest of webx and where we fit in
So I guess finally from a from a demo perspective as well. I do want to touch on that. Um, you know, we mentioned, um
I guess some differentiators from us and others in the marketplace and certainly the webx advantage is one of them
Um, I'm going to show you a little bit around how we fit in to webx in general
Um, I think our aim is to power great custom experiences as webx for businesses to support their transformation
So we are one element of that and we are just one solution within the webx cx portfolio
We are fully webx branded products alongside the contact center solution
Which we've heavily integrated with and I'll show you an example of that in a minute
And of course our our ucast platform or the webx app, which includes calling messages and meetings
And so we are able to leverage our webx technology and capabilities to enhance
our cx products essentially, which I'll now show you now with two
examples, so I'm going to show you um
A c path digital channel capability in the contact center, which I mentioned
But also how c pass can integrate with the webx platform as well for a really powerful use case
So first up in this demo, we have a chat bot journey essentially over sms
So we've jumped in halfway through
The customer has now requested escalation to an agent
We've tried to triage them and automate them as much as possible as we showed in a previous example
But at this point we can package up
All of the previous conversation all of the history of this
Automated conversation we have when the customer responds chat within our flow builder
We package this up and we hand it off into webx contact center
And you can see these these nodes out of the box here that are performing those tasks
And so when the agent logs into webx contact center, they can easily pick up this chat in their queue
They ensure that we ensure that they have the full context across the entire conversation
So the customer doesn't have to repeat themselves
The agent doesn't have to ask them questions
The agent can be productive as all the information available to them
And once they pick up the chat, there's no bouncing the customer around into live chat through links, etc
They stay in the sms channel that they entered in their channel of choice
Or whatever channel they came in via
It's seamless. It's easy and it's a happy agent and happy customer
And secondarily, I I'm just going to show you how we do this in a slightly different environment with the webx app
So here you see again
It's a customer conversation
The customer's trying to self serve that they're in an automotive situation
But they're not talking to a customer service agent here
They're they're they're automating with a dealership a car dealership and the employees on the ground are remote
So at this point when we want to package this up and hand it over we have to do something a little different
We're actually going to pass it into the webx app because the agent can be or the the agent inverted commons can be
Deskless and can be walking around using the app. So in this instance, we package everything up as you see here
We're ensuring all of the context is handed across again
The agent can pick up the conversation moving to a one-to-one chat with the customer whilst letting the team know
It's been assigned and they can pick it up like
Nothing had happened before again
The customer has a seamless experience on their channel of choice. They could be on sms. What's app insert channel
The dealership staff in this case are empowered and the business have a fully auditable conversation for their records
Avoid personal devices being used and I think in the financial services space right now. That's a really top
hot topic for
Avoiding huge industry fines. It's got a lot pr at the minute
um
It's a really powerful solution
to demonstrate
I guess a solution that integrates with the webx app across a deskless workforce
So to summarize and and to finish
um
We have a proven
centralized communications platform. This means providing tools to invite
The entire enterprise to collaborate to building great cx as we mentioned make developers more efficient
low code tools
economies of scale reuse of integrations all that great stuff
In the second column, we've got enterprise grade. I mentioned the word enterprise grade over and over again
Hopefully resonated so greater controls slas regional instances dc security
A platform benefits from being part of sysfo implement the highest standards that they maintain across security
And we recognize that that is a critical need in the large enterprise
high touch arena
And finally the webx advantage as I showcase the integrations we have with contact center and the app
We live with customers in market with those today. These aren't in beta. These are things we're doing with other customers
We'd love to tell you more about some of those in your
Sector or space or even outside of your sector
And this actually goes beyond just webx, you know, we've we've explored broader sysco integrations into
maraki's network d.a spaces location-based technology
thousand eyes at d
Monitoring software. So again, we would love to help
Explore how cpass can help you take advantage of your other investments in sysco as well
Thanks for staying with me and listening to this
I hope you understood a little bit more about the platform and enjoyed some of these videos we provided for you
I'm David Jennings and have a good day